so there are lots of different types of
exercise and I'm gonna try to go through
some of the important types of exercise
and talk about how you might want to set
up your own exercise routine if you're
thinking about starting so I've drawn
your little person in yellow and they're
stretching and this is something that
people often forget this is an important
type of exercise that isn't actually
critical to do I would say about five
times a week so you really want to
stretch out at least about five times
each week all the different muscle
groups and we have a total of about 11
different muscle groups major muscle
groups and you want to spend about 30
seconds on each one of them so whatever
you're stretching just think about all
the different muscle groups and think
about spending at least 30 seconds per
muscle group write that out and as I
said there are 11 so this whole thing
could take you about five or six minutes
and one key I'll write down for
stretching so make sure you're doing it
right is make sure you do it with warm
muscles basically don't start stretching
cold in other words if you haven't done
anything at all now let's say it's the
afternoon you feel like stretching don't
start stretching just there go for a
brisk walk first or maybe go and do a
flight of stairs just something to get
your muscles moving and then you can
start stretching it's really the best
way and also don't bounce so don't
bounce when you're actually doing this
stretch try to go slowly and evenly into
the stretch and then also out of the
stretch so no bounce actually right no
bouncing and also warm muscles just to
remind you to make sure that the muscles
are slightly warm or or having done
something before is a good idea so the
next type of exercise would be aerobic
exercise so aerobic exercise would be
anything let's have this person maybe
running and this could be biking or
running anything like that would count
as an aerobic exercise and aerobic
exercise you really want to also do
about five times
per week and these are these are not
maximum but really suggested numbers of
times let's say you want to do six times
a week that would be absolutely fine and
here again as before you want to give
some sort of a set amount of time and
usually I recommend about thirty minutes
it's about thirty minutes of good
aerobic exercise and that's per per time
you go out so 30 minutes per time and
then five of those times per week okay
and then you have probably the third
type I would group as resistance
training and this would be someone
that's maybe let's say lifting weights
I'm going to draw someone lifting
weights
and with resistance training there are a
few important things to consider and
this is probably the one that where a
lot of people get into trouble with
injuries and things like that resistance
training you want to do I would say
probably about two times a week
especially if you're starting out I'd be
a very reasonable thing to start out at
two times a week and each time you go
you want to make sure you work out each
muscle group and usually I recommend
about ten repetitions of any exercise so
let's say you're doing an exercise to
work out your chest try to do 10
repetitions per muscle group and you
have to try to figure out what amount of
resistance is the right amount for you
and so you want to make sure that ten
repetitions is doable but you don't
wanna make it so easy that that you
don't feel like you're actually getting
much of a workout at all that your
muscles aren't having any trouble so
finding that right weight can be tricky
at first and with resistance training
one of the keys is making sure as I said
you don't injure yourself or hurt
yourself so you want to make sure you
don't do it in any situation where
you're actually feeling pain to the
point where you think you could be
actually harming your body instead of
actually helping your body and you also
want your body to rest so allow rest
of at least a day I'll put more than one
day for whichever muscle group you've
just worked out so for example if I just
worked out my legs my quadriceps I don't
want to go back and work them out
you know the very next day I want at
least a day of rest or or more than a
day for each muscle group okay so you've
got these three different types of
exercise stretching aerobic exercise and
resistance and I thought it might be
kind of helpful to imagine how we could
do this so let's say let's do an example
of how a person could actually go about
making a little exercise routine given
this information so you might want let's
say a warmup period because I said that
you want to make sure you don't do the
stretching cold so you might want to
warm up and this could be something like
doing some stairs or going for a brisk
walk and that can be let's say five
minutes and then you could do some
stretching all right that is a yellow
block with an S and then you could do
some aerobic exercise and that could be
like a 30 minute treadmill or a 30
minute racquetball game or anything like
that and finally you want to do the
resistance training and you could focus
on let's say five of the eleven muscle
groups this time and then do the other
six later on a different day and so just
on this day let's imagine this is Monday
this is what it would look like this
would be Monday and this whole thing
might take me let's say one hour and
then I might go back and let's say on a
different day I decided to do stretching
and aerobic exercise like this and I
want to make sure I give myself a rest
with my muscles with the resistance
training so I may not do resistance
today so I might on Tuesday and
Wednesday I'll do this
and then on let's say Thursday actually
let's say all three days I can do this
just to make it easier
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday I could do
that and then on Friday I can actually
go back do the warm-up again as before I
can stretch as before remember you're
stretching all 11 muscle groups and then
I do the aerobic exercise and you can
change it up just to make it interesting
you could on this day let's say you
actually go for a swim and then you do
your resistance training and you could
focus on different muscle groups there
from Monday and this could be your
Friday so for example sometimes people
say well on Monday I worked on my legs
and on Friday I worked on my chest and
arms and that would be a way of kind of
dividing up which muscle groups you
worked on so that you're not too sore in
any one area and so you can see how
you've met all the criteria I said you
know try to do the stretching in aerobic
exercise five times a week in resistance
a couple times a week and my little
example schedule you can see how that
could work out and just be clear these
little wedges again are the warm-ups and
the cooldowns so let me bring it back to
some big keys some big keys to having a
successful workout because I think this
is probably the most understated part of
working out but probably makes the most
sense to focus on this now now that
we've talked about some the other issues
so anytime you workout please make sure
that you stay well hydrated because this
is one of the most important things that
you need to do to have a successful
workout to feel good to make sure that
the blood is flowing and that you don't
you know pass out from having too little
fluid in your body so you want to make
sure you get lots of water in your body
nice healthy healthy way to go next you
want to make sure you're dressed very
comfortably this is another problem that
a lot of people end up having is that
they they go to a workout but they're
not actually dressed well for it and
they find that it's not very comfortable
so dress
appropriately topic loads think about
drinking a lot of water and wearing the
right clothes and finally and this is
probably the most important point I want
to leave it for last because then it's
the last thing you remember hopefully
and from this video but the but the most
important thing is to use good judgement
this is a little brain and you want to
make sure you're always thinking about
what you're about to do so judgment so
for example let's say that you're you're
recently injured and you're thinking
about doing some sort of aerobic
exercise think really carefully about
what what could be a good idea what
might not be a good idea for example
it's hard to get into specifics without
giving an example but let's say that you
just had a knee injury or knee operation
you may not want to go running because
you might want to think about not re
injuring that knee and so anytime you've
had an operation or you've recently been
injured you definitely want to make sure
that it's a good idea and that's my
light bulb there it's a good idea to do
the right type of exercise so that you
don't end up re-entering or hurting
yourself further the whole point of this
is to make sure that we're getting
healthy or not not hurting ourselves in
any way so make sure you always use good
judgment